let me briefly mention to you that
Donald Trump exploded yesterday and
today on Truth social as a second Trump
arrest is now looming and the Fox News
Dominion trial is set to start it was
set to start today it got pushed to
tomorrow but even that there's
speculation that maybe Fox News is going
to settle
and Fox News is sort of stuck between a
rock and a hard place here because on
the one hand if Fox News settles the
Dominion lawsuit
even if they are not literally admitting
fault they are admitting fault but
you're settling it if you were if you
actually were right here if you didn't
do the things you're accused of if you
were right to air the the things you
aired and if Trump really did win 2020
then why are you settling if they don't
settle they risk an even bigger bigger
loss weeks of humiliating headlines and
it's I don't envy the position Fox News
is in it's of course their fault that
they're in this position to begin with
Trump's idea which he posted to truth
social is Fox News should just insist
that Trump really did win in 2020. truth
essential Trump posting to truth this
morning in all capital letters if Fox
would finally admit that there was
large-scale cheating and irregularities
in the 2020 presidential election which
would be a good thing for them and for
America the case against them which
should not have existed at all would be
greatly weakened backup back up those
Patriots at Fox instead of throwing them
under the bus and they are right there
is so much proof like Mass ballot
stuffing caught on government cameras
FBI colluding with Twitter and Facebook
State legislatures not used
Etc now Trump isn't wrong well let me
how do I even say this
a defense to defamation is that the
things you said are true
that is accurate you can defend yourself
against defamation by saying it's it
can't be defamation because I stated
truth or truth depending on your
preference of course the idea that Fox
News would try to get itself out of this
by going and making a case that Trump
actually won the 2020 election would be
so humiliating and laughable that it
could potentially be the worst possible
outcome for Fox News of all of it but
that's Donald Trump's legal advice take
it for what it's worth and then
yesterday Trump trothing also in all
capital letters quote so the Democrats
are allowed to cheat on and rig and he
spells rig with two G's which is
interesting Democrats are allowed to
cheat on and rig
a presidential election and they want to
indict Republicans for a campaign
violation this is classic so the
totality of this is Trump has been
arrested and indicted he thinks it's
politically motivated he thinks it's
bogus he thinks even if he did the thing
he's accused of it's very minor compared
to the theft of an election that he
actually won and his legal advice to Fox
on this issue is settle don't settle
fight it by arguing that I really won
which is maybe the craziest legal advice
that I've ever heard I hope
Fox does not settle the lawsuit and I
hope that we get six weeks potentially
of embarrassing humiliating and insane
headlines related to that trial which by
the way will have the sort of side
benefit of being endlessly triggering to
the failed former president
one of our sponsors is betterhelp I am a
huge believer in therapy let's say
you've been thinking for a while about
getting into therapy you know it's the
right move you have things you'd like to
talk to someone about there is no better
time than the present but you don't have
to drive across town every week and sit
in a waiting room because of better help
better help is the world's largest
therapy service it's 100 online with
better help you can tap into a network
of over 25
000 licensed and experienced therapists
specializing in a wide range of issues
you answer a few questions about
yourself and better help will match you
with a therapist based on your specific
needs and preferences the sessions can
be on the phone video call chat anytime
anywhere from your couch at home from
your office at work and if your
therapist isn't the right fit you can
switch anytime at no charge my audience
gets 10 off your first month at better
help.com slash Pacman the link is down
below